24 year old julio urias who just really
has not been able to put it together yet
this season the era below four but last
three games dra close to six george
springer will lead it off springer
batting 234 344 on base percentage eight
homers 22 rbis springer grounds one down
the left field line into the corner
and the mvp of the 2017 world series has
a double to lead things off springer a
leadoff double at second base one out
and julio delivers the 2-2 and brentley
hits a sharp one hopper diving stop by
[ __ ] hernandez he throws onto first to
retire brantley hernandez had to dive to
his armed side right one hop shot got up
in plenty of time to throw out bradley
with springer advancing to third so two
man out so two out and springer at third
for julie gurion that's hit in the air
out to shallow center field and
hernandez can't make the catch it drops
in as springer scores guriel is on at
first base with an rbi single to make it
one-nothing astros kiki made a swipe at
it but couldn't grab it from the
dominican fromber valdez who's mostly
out of the bullpen over his first two
years in the majors but the rotation
pretty much full time here with the
injuries they've had john yeah a similar
track record to uria's first three
starts were really good the last three
have been a little bumpy one out of
nobody on for corey seeger the shortstop
adding 314 365 on base percentage and
that's a ground ball right side diving
stopped by correa to his left in the
shift gets up and throws to first in
time to get seeger correa was to the
right of second he fielded that ball to
step into the outfield and was able to
pop up and get the out two out here's
chris taylor on the start center field
tonight but a guy who plays all over for
the damages he swings and taylor hits a
long drive to right field going back is
reddick he's at the track he's at the
wall he leaps it's gone into the home
run seats a two out two run home run for
chris taylor and the dodgers take the
lead 2-1 home run number four for taylor
hitters love the 3-0 count why well you
have two mistakes that you can make the
pitcher only has one that he can make
you're going to be on base with a walk
to begin with so the dodgers have the
lead there are two outs for [ __ ]
hernandez the second baseman sends one
that direction redick's going back on
this as well they've gone back to back
the other way taylor then hernandez
seven and eight hitters in the dodger
lineup back-to-back pitches
back-to-back opposite field home runs
seekers at third one away for aj pollock
put muncie on deck this ball hit in the
air to deep right it'll be playable for
reddick he makes the over-the-shoulder
catch on the warning track tagging and
scoring is seeger sacrifice fly by
pollock makes it four to one dodging
odes has done a nice job settling in
after the back-to-back home runs in the
second one more up in the third but he's
retired six straight since
he gets luck swinging two out that draws
the five-pitch walk first one issued by
fraumber tonight it comes with two out
look look out fastball still seeker the
storm position goes back that's not a
good good picture of the hitter now with
two men out the dodgers have a man in
scoring position and this ball is shot
into left field on the ground a base hit
betsy's rounding third he's on his way
to the plate here comes the throw mookie
slides and he pops up safely it's a
two-out rbi b set for corey seeger and
the dodgers with a 5-1 lead yeah knock
me down i'll do some damage that's
exactly what seeger did bennett first
and second and two men out swung on and
fisted into shallow center taylor on the
run he's going to get under it and make
the catch julio arias is done in what is
one of his best starts of the year made
up an earned run on three hits walk four
struck out three and he is the pitcher
of record to the good right here for the
dodgers at the corners with two gone and
it brings up [ __ ] hernandez it's at the
top of the zone to get hernandez
straight through only the second hit for
the astros since the first inning
so diaz on second base here's reddick
over two down swinging his reddick first
pitch and he hits this one hard left
side it's gonna be muncie the third
baseman
and he's gonna throw him out for the
third out of the end so that's
a little something going with runners at
the corners that's a ground ball up the
middle backhanded by hernandez to the
left of second race is the second steps
on the back throws the first knot in
time hernandez's momentum when he feel
that that was carrying him away from
second he had to put on the brakes and
change direction just to get one out on
that as a run comes home breckman comes
in and it is five to two l.a for the
ninth inning kenley jansen so much of
the dodgers hopes in this 2020 season
and in any season
fought on the shoulders of their long
time closure dodgers by three tying run
at the plate in the form of josh reddick
and reddick lines this one toward left
center field that one is headed for the
gap and it's down for a base hit correa
is going to score the relay by seeger
not nearly in time it's a two-run double
for josh reddick in the astros trail by
a run five to four first and third for
the astros back to the top of the order
in george springer and springer lines
this one through the left side that's a
base hit that'll score another as
reddick ties the game
five to five bregman will stand in
and this ball is lifted in the center
field that'll get down for a base
hitting right center that'll score the
go-ahead run as mayfield comes home it's
six to five astros and have taken jansen
out of the game six batters they all get
hits running up there two gone ninth
inning
swinging
picked out of the dirt by garneau he
tags out lux and that is the ball game